[Music]
2004 NASA's Opportunity rover lands on
Mars
part of its mission is to search for
evidence that water return to Mars after
the borealis impact it's not long before
opportunity's stumbles across something
strange on the surface of a fossilized
sand dune bizarre ground metallic rocks
these rocks are called blueberries and
they're an important find for planetary
geologists like Jani radabaugh because
fossilized sand dunes also exist on
earth and Utah's petrified dunes are
littered with blueberries - this is
really exciting because we've seen the
exact same thing on Mars
blueberries are nodules of iron oxide
that form deep underground finding
similar higher nodules on Mars is
significant because they must have
formed after the borealis impact melted
the planet and they're created by water
in order to form one of these little
blueberries there needs to be huge
amounts of water flushing down through
the fossil sand dunes and as it does
that it carries with it all of the iron
oxides around each sand grain and just
one tiny little one like this now this
is maybe about an ounce of iron maybe a
little bit more and in order to get an
ounce of iron to concentrate into this
blueberry you need to have a thousand
gallons of water
blueberries form deep inside sandstone
but over thousands of years wind erosion
blows away the softer Rock leaving just
the blueberries behind
we walked to the edge of this pile of
blueberries we can see the process by
which they're actually roading out of
the rock the blueberry is right here
contained within this fossil sandstone
layer the winds are blowing in this
direction down the layers and there
they're actually eroding out the soft
sand stones right here and leaving
behind the very dense iron nodules and
as they pluck themselves out of the rock
they roll down the hill and then collect
right here in between layers we know
we've found conditions just like this on
Mars we have fossil sand dune layers we
also have blueberries all over the
surface so we know the same kinds of
things had to have happened on Mars that
have happened here there has to be water
flowing through the rock gathering iron
and then there has to be a huge amount
of wind to strip away the fossil sand
dunes